hello everyone and welcome to a most
exciting game that happened some nine
days ago it was a part of a part of a
stream battle between blood stream and
Aleksandra botas and it's a game between
Canadian PD master Antonian Atanasoff
who is 12 years old against the
Grandmaster Fabian liebe share scheme
now a former coach of the French
national team a very strong player and
as the title suggests it is a very short
game but a very exciting one so without
further ado let's check it out and also
if you want to check out this game as it
was actually played I will put a link in
the description below with a timestamp
when the game begins so you can check
that out as well in the original video
so Anthony opens with d4 now we have g6
so going for the modern defense we have
Bishop the f4 white going for the London
system setup and the Bishop to g7 sorry
about that just nicely continuing
development with III also just like I
said going for the London setup and d6
now black wants to play Knight d7 and
strike in the center with E 5 we have
Knight to f3 and now Knight to d7 black
continues with his plan and Bishop to c4
and now this is played black will
sometimes go go for this setup and
usually you will go for a six or maybe
e5 you're gonna go for h6 button to move
a black place here completely blunders
the game here black plays b6 and now
black is completely lost so pause the
video here and try to figure out how to
win this with white while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on spotting that night and d7 completely
blocks in the black queen and the black
queen if the black queen is under attack
the black queen is lost and this gives a
white the motive to sacrifice the bishop
on f7 so for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show
it's Bishop captures on f7 with check
and now you don't have to accept the
bishop however it's a very difficult to
play if you don't for example Knight
comes to g5 again nice the e6 is the
threat of just winning the Queen and
after you open up the bishops defense of
the e6 square Queen to f3 attacking the
rook here and just putting the Queen
very nice square attacking the King and
well there's not much you can do it's
age six black could offer to give back
some material to relieve the attack
however just nice to e6 check captures
captures and it will be a very difficult
position to play for black black is
completely lost here and not not much
you can do here very hard to even
develop any pieces however lebakowski
decided to capture the bishop here and
this is where things get interesting
so King captures on f7 and now Knight
captures and g5 and now King to f6 the
problem is if you go back then nice the
knight to the e6 indeed traps the Queen
the Queen has nowhere to go and if
instead of here you go here then just
nice the e6 check again picks up the
Queen instantly so after Knight to g5
check we have King to f6 and now Queen
to f3 putting pressure on the rook but
also threatening a lot of nasty
discoveries here with the bishop so
black found a way to try and give back
some material to survive the attack you
played Bishop to b7 now putting pressure
on the Queen hoping for Queen captures
on b7 however white has a forced
checkmate in four so once again feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the winning idea for white here there
are a lot of them of course you have to
find the quickest one and there is even
a hint above the board so there you go
while I give you a couple of seconds so
photos you just who were able to do it
congratulations on forcing this lazy
King to flee in the face of a double
check and for those who just want to
enjoy the show it's Bishop to e5 check
check from the bishop and from the Queen
so black does not have the opportunity
to grab the Queen and the only move
available to the black King is to
capture this Knight
so this is taken by the night by the
knight this isn't guarded by the pawn so
you have to go for King captures and g5
but now as the Queen covers the entire F
file now it's a fairly simple h4 check
King to h6 only move and now Queen to f4
check and here if you go back g4 is
checkmate so black played the g5 but it
doesn't really help Queen captures and
g5 is now checkmate so there are a lot
of miniature
but this one I really enjoyed it
features a sacrifice an f7 features a
nice discovery black even tried to give
back some material so a lot of things
happening in 12 moves but the game does
end in in in move 12 with a checkmate
and g5 so really a beautiful game I
really do hope you enjoyed it congratu
congratulations to young Anthony on
achieving this masterpiece against a
grandmaster so very very impressive and
yeah I would also like to thank a
Valentin Borrelia for suggesting this
game to me and he also said that if you
guys are interested in challenging him
to a game his chest calm username is
evolved which will also be in the
description below so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Henry hunt Toby Pirtle Thomas
Connors Ricardo patron and max Caroline
Caroline for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the clutch
international checking up on your
wonderful suggestions such as this one
and of course whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day